season two guys yeah I feel like
channeling my blood lust is key to
preventing something like last night's
oopsie does she become more aggressive
this is the new normal
yeah we just you have to eat people yeah
and I think you know with that comes
sort of new skill sets from Sheila angel
of how they're gonna take on their new
normal and our daughter Abbey and our
neighbor Eric kind of take on their own
vigilantes storylines we're still trying
to juggle everyday life as well exactly
was enough yeah she finds a group of
people trying to sell though there's
some cool crazy real real estate
business yeah raise a teenager and then
there's the killing and eating people
yeah and they know you're worried I'm
gonna go out there and kill somebody but
think about all the people I haven't
killed literally everyone in the world
except three people no you guys play
Realtors yeah would you guys be good
Realtors do you know how to sell yeah
[Music]
and also I love anything realtor or
house oriented and I was so excited when
I found out that was their jobs in the
beginning I love reality and going into
people's homes I love everything about I
like I move all the time I have the same
house in LA I've had for like almost 20
years but I'm always like trying a new
city and a new apartment I always go
trick-or-treating with the kids yeah
check out the houses yeah the kids would
be like dad there's no one at this house
you're like when else will we get to go
up to the front door every time I see a
house in a neighborhood - I always
fantasize about what would my life be
here I like I play a little game with
myself and it's drew moved she
definitely need a big house with two
daughters and three newly adopted
kittens you have three kittens oh my god
and I have ringworm right now I'm in a
total nightmare right now it went from
like yeah we have three baby kittens to
like they have bring worms do you know
what ringworm is it's a
nightmare it's contagious it's hell you
don't want to know me before anyone was
at a cat with ringworm just it's like oh
jeez its cuddly and you can get it a
horrible situation yeah my vet texted me
other day you will get through this I'm
like hopefully your vets texting you dr.
grey
[Laughter]